los residentes fueron sorprendidos
durante la noche un misil Ruso impactó
en este edificio del centro de la ciudad
entre los escombros los equipos de
rescate encontraron a la primera víctima
hay varias más ahora intentan Localizar
a los posibles supervivientes el
edificio quedó completamente destruido y
siete otros han sufrido daños
primero oí un silbido luego todo empezó
a temblar en Twitter el presidente
ucraniano condenó el ataque bolodimir
selens que reconoce que la situación en
el este del país es cada vez más
complicada
Rusia quiere ganar terreno a medida que
se acerca el aniversario de la invasión
en esas circunstancias todos debemos
estar especialmente Unidos y
especialmente centrados en los intereses
del estado y en consecuencia
especialmente resilientes según kiev se
está preparando una nueva ofensiva de
Moscú para las próximas semanas en el
terreno el ejército ruso avanza
principalmente al norte y al sur de
bahmud una ciudad estratégica en la
región del Don vass que se ha convertido
en el principal objetivo de Rusia en los
últimos meses